I had a clip recently come across before
you talking about uh I'd cap that yeah
from 100 years ago yeah
and I was like no that clip was very
recent but no no
the original clip of you in like 2012 13
were you still in college then no it was
that was my first year out of college
damn yeah yeah the one of the original
interviews you you look so young that's
the first interview media thing I've
ever done yeah in my entire life and I
remember thinking that like literally
like I was the next Mark Zuckerberg
because of that I was like who wants
they want a Pando daily wants to
interview me right because you had a
picture I can you and your next stop
your friend and it said Deez Nuts yeah
exactly
Zuck here I come
damn
yeah like this is gonna change the world
well you think a million dollars is cool
what about these nuts
how about both of us
yeah that was wild yeah literally I have
watched you through all of that is that
weird yeah very strange yeah it's very I
I'm starting to feel this like
um
because I've been doing this for what
four years now
and I'm already like God remember when I
can't imagine like having a career that
has spanned that long on the internet
how do you do you look back in cringe or
are you like oh my God okay yeah yeah
100 so it's not like damn I was still a
third person no
body sure I don't know I'm like [__]
embarrassed and just sure yeah but
you're killing it
it's fun it's it's been fun I stay busy
um what are you working on these days
I'm making a show on YouTube okay and
I've talked about before how it's kind
of medieval themed okay and um that's
all I want to say okay and I also have a
podcast coming out okay and uh that's
all I want to say on that as well
cool
so get ready for that and then also open
conversations like this no honestly
don't ask me any follow-up questions
don't ask for any details
because you know it's like what if
something I'm talking about it now and
it's totally different in two months
yeah true it's a little makes me a
little nervous yeah but it's uh it's
very fun and but you were you've also
been in you were in Super Bowl
commercial a Super Bowl commercial or
something yeah girl I was in the [__]
Sabra hummus Super Bowl commercial were
you really 2019 and they oh 2019. in
2019. okay and uh it was so humiliating
they had me come in the kombucha video
had just happened okay and they were
like we want you
and Charlie demilio and I was like okay
the two most famous women on the planet
yeah yeah yeah
as you should of course yes we're a
package Duo
I was like okay they were like we want
you to do the face and I said okay and
so I came in and did it and we did I'm
not joking it was this gross like
chocolate hummus and I had to what yeah
and I had to dip strawberries in it
apparently don't know if it's still on
the market I had to dip strawberries in
it try it do the face
50 times someone that's poor yeah
this poor like 50 year old man had a
spit bucket just like each time
and he's reaching in there and eating it
afterwards
it's got a big spoon
that's gross kinda it's gross kind of
and they put me in the Glam chair for
this I got glammed to do that wow I was
like I think don't think I've ever
looked worse actually that's actually
like the worst I've ever looked what's
with the orange and the so that was the
whole thing it was like color oh there's
my bestie Charlie
did you get paid I did get paid like a
lot at at the time to me like five
thousand dollars was like there's no
larger amount of money like wait they
paid you five thousand dollars no they
didn't pay me five thousand but like
that was at the time I was like holy
[__] because that is a lot of money I
was making 39 000 a year I know but for
like a nationally syndicated Super Bowl
commercial I feel like you they'd pay
you like a million what hell no okay it
was not it wasn't much more than 5K it
was around that because but then don't
you get like royalty checks and [__] for
no because it only plays once right well
you would think you know because this is
a YouTube video like it would keep her
no no like I signed all that away this
was so early in my career I was like oh
Super Bowl commercial come here yeah I
mean I would have done it right sure but
looking back obviously I'm not
I wasn't to the point where I am now
back then so the rates are very
different but yeah I was not paid a lot
for this huh like yeah because I always
thought like as an actor like if you get
a big nationally shown commercial like
that it's like oh that'll pay for your
entire year sure it's different for like
[__] John Travolta no I meant it's
like I have friends that like weren't
acting in any you know any like shows or
anything but they would get a commercial
for like T-Mobile or something and they
make 100 Grand speaking of T-Mobile I
just did something with T-Mobile
um this is a bit I did it was a bit
online okay where they were like we want
you to create some social cuts for the
Super Bowl commercial and I was supposed
to be in the extended version on Youtube
hold on so you were in T-Mobile Super
Bowl commercial now I was supposed to be
my Madison Beer moment I was supposed to
be in the video yeah
and uh they were like yeah we filmed
this whole bit for the Extended Cut and
like I was kind of excited and then they
were like actually we're not gonna use
it but I it was like a grease Recreation
John Travolta was in it and they were
singing about internet I don't know okay
and uh I did this cut for socials where
I acted like I was the director and so I
was like going up behind people on set
being like could we bring the lights yep
actually no we're gonna talk to my guys
about it like just being so [__]
annoying okay and everyone said I was
like what's she doing well I filmed all
of it and I uploaded it my fans love you
guys but it was a joke they were like so
proud of my girl knew she could do it
like she directed this watching the
T-Mobile commercial because my bestie
director
the real director was like what the [__]
ing stuff like so bad because he's like
what the [__] moment and it was so funny
because I had to keep being like I
didn't it's a joke it's a joke obviously
you're replying to every single comment
hey thanks for the support but this is a
joke
love you so much thank you so much this
is a joke though yeah please I'm
actually joking yeah it was funny though
because everyone was music can we play
it
um it's royalty free music you can't
play oh let's go
set
for the filmographer it's a lot it's a
lot to you know filmographer but it's I
actually invented that time that's the
money shot good work guys
I mean it's clearly a joke it's clearly
a joke people were like I'm so proud of
her
[Music]
people like to work on set with these
guys you know
zero idea
that is so clearly a joke yeah so
clearly but people were so and it was so
cute because they were like I knew you
could do it like thanks but I didn't I
didn't do nothing but were you like
maybe I can yeah I was like damn this
this is kind of easy huh yeah
so you were in this and then they cut
you out
why
a dart Gnar and did they tell you or did
they wait until you were like oh like
guys let's like you host like a Super
Bowl watch party because you're like I'm
in one of the commercials this place
30 minutes into the game oh this is it
this is it guys guys
just do it
okay
and then the commercial ends yeah I'm
like
could you rewind do you guys have Evo
could you rewind it actually I think
there was a second where nope
oh it must be a different one yeah yeah
it's actually later in the game they
told me different brand sorry it was
mint mobile that I was it's my fault no
uh they told me so last minute like
we're actually
wow that sucks it does suck but did they
pay you of course okay okay that's kind
of why I was like that's all right
because I was like you know what I was
on set I did you know my deliverables
whatever and then it was fine but I was
like that's so funny to be like well I
was actually supposed to be a Super Bowl
commercial but you're not yeah no no I'm
not but yeah I was on set I filmed me
the footage is on the hard drive so
exactly I got yelled at by security you
know it was the whole thing I'm in the
director's cut
so what does that mean yeah well well
it's on the DVD like if you get the
you go to menu and you go to delete it
deleted scenes and I'll be in that one
yeah yeah so it's actually it was really
cool cool opportunity so what like now
so you've been cast now for two Super
Bowl commercials that's really cool
that's [__] wild it is [__] wild
yeah that's that's never thought about
that before yeah
yeah it's cool I've been cast for zero
well they're gonna draft you into the
actual team that goes next year oh I've
heard Whispers I've heard rumors yeah
really yeah okay yeah they're actually
like sacking everyone it's just gonna be
like five eight honey funny and they're
all just gonna like run around I could
play football all right they give y'all
mics you're running around like trying
to do stand up
they're like okay Cody trains train okay
I'm gonna literally do the gritty on to
the end zone I mean we're like quitting
on the field I mean we're not gritty in
front of Dallas Cowboy Cheerleaders
boobies have you seen that little
Sasquatch video where they're like he's
like watching the NBA draft and they're
like and uh from Ohio little Sasquatch
he's like holy [__] did I just get
drafted and he calls his mom and he's
like yeah I don't know yeah I'm gonna do
it because like it's so funny he's so
[__] funny